und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend das beste hoffen auf das
schlimmste vorbereiten so hat der
bundeswirtschaftsminister die lage
zusammen gefasst seit heute morgen
fließt durch nord stream 1 kein gas mehr
aus russland nach deutschland
das an sich wäre routine die pipeline
wird gewartet das war auch angekündigt
aber weder robert habeck noch sonst
jemand hierzulande weiß ob in zehn bis
14 tagen das gas dann wieder fließt oder
ob putin ist gleich ganz abgedreht lässt
und so müssen sich alle miteinander in
die versorger industriebetriebe und
private haushalte jetzt schon fragen was
wenn nicht elisabeth schmidt berichtet
auch hier beobachten sie den ganz krimi
ganz genau energieversorger enercity in
hannover das unternehmen arbeitet
derzeit notfallpläne aus sollte russland
gar kein gas mehr liefern dann sind
zuerst die kunden dran deren verträge es
zulassen dass sie abgeschaltet werden
das heißt die sich freiwillig dazu
gemietet haben dann kommen die
sogenannten nicht geschützten kunden und
ganz zum schluss im allerletzten fall
sind die geschützten kunden dran das
sind die privathaushalte das sind
krankenhäuser becker hier wird man
zuerst sehen ob gas mangel droht lubmin
mecklenburg vorpommern seit sechs uhr
morgens hat russland hier an der nord
stream-pipeline das gas abgestellt zehn
tage technik-check routine eigentlich es
gibt ganz widersprüchliche signale
die gehen von tatsächlich der reduktion
auf null es könnte auch alles bei den 40
prozent bleiben die wir momentan haben
es weiß keiner und womöglich ist diese
unsicherheit auch teil einer seit mitte
juni fließen nur noch 40 prozent erdgas
über die pipeline nach deutschland
russland begründet das mit einer
fehlenden gasturbine von siemens die
jetzt aber geliefert wird viele
vorgeschobene gründe sagt der
wirtschaftsminister heute in prag und
wird für gegenseitige unterstützung in
europa bei der gasversorgung wir
brauchen gas aus norwegen wir brauchen
gas aus den niederlanden wir brauchen
die importe im südeuropäischen raum wir
kommen in dieser situation nur weiter
wenn wir uns gegenseitig helfen die ganz
speicher in deutschland sind erst zu 65
prozent gefüllt sollte russland den
gashahn zugedreht lassen droht im
nächsten jahr eine versorgungslücke mit
einer wahrscheinlichkeit von weniger als
20 prozent haben forscher aus kiel
berechnet also worst case szenario wenn
es nicht gelingt ausreichend gas am
weltmarkt zu beschaffen derzeit
reduzierte die industrie ihren
gasverbrauch schon massiv wir sind schon
bei über zehn prozent
verbrauchsreduktion da ist deutlich mehr
drin auch kurzfristig wie viel einsparen
auf wieviel verzichten alles hängt davon
ab ob wir in einer guten woche wieder
russisches erdgas ankommt turbulente
zeiten für gaskunden und
energieversorger
das gas knapp die inflationsrate schon
jetzt so hoch wie seit jahrzehnten nicht
und das zu einer zeit in der die
wirtschaft eh schon pandemie geschwächt
ist wie schlimm wird es werden vor allem
wie teuer wird es werden das sind die
fragen die jetzt viele umtreiben
bundeskanzler scholz will sich offenbar
nicht länger vorwerfen lassen er würde
nicht genügend kommunizieren und hält
jetzt in großem stil
bürgersprechstunden ab im fernsehen und
in real es soll eine ganze reihe
sogenannter dialog veranstaltungen quer
durch die republik geben auftakt war
heute in lübeck lars thomsen und hermann
berichten
der kanzler sucht den dialog mit den
bürgern in schwierigen zeiten für den
hamburger fast ein heimspiel
das gefällt mir natürlich gut hanse
hafen willy brandt alles passt die
tragen während der eineinhalbstündigen
veranstaltung moderat eines musste der
kanzler allerdings gleich einräumen die
herausforderung werden so schnell nicht
kleiner werden
glaube ich sind schon sehr sehr ernste
zeiten in den wert leben und ich bin
ganz sicher die bürgern und bürger des
landes wissen das auch ganz genau und
sie wissen auch dass das eine situation
ist in der man wirklich nichts falsch
machen darf der bundeskanzler bemüht
bedrohliche entwicklung betont ruhig
abzuhandeln etwa den angriff auf die
ukraine wenn das einmal geklappt hat
könnte jemand sein dann mache ich das
noch mal woanders
und deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir die
unterstützung leisten
auf kritik an der hochzeit von
finanzminister lindner auf sylt bei der
der kanzler selbst zu gast mal regiert
er mit gefühlen
ihre mitglied im bundeskabinett groß
gefeierte fehlt und dass wenn die
staatlichen diese zeit das schönste im
leben ist die liebe und wenn zwei sich
finden und heiraten wollen sollte man
ihn nicht allzuviel reinreden
überraschende einblicke in die aktuelle
lage gab es nicht aber
ich sagen viele sachen sind in planung
also ich habe denn da auch mal ein
bisschen vertrauen das ist irgendwie gut
läuft
dass leib zu rücken dass er das dann
auch alles umsetzen was er vorhat
immerhin ein abend in ihr zwischen
bürgern und politik
europa wird sich jedenfalls im wahrsten
sinne des wortes warm anziehen müssen
denn nach einem baldigen ende des
krieges sieht es nicht aus putin hat
jetzt angekündigt allen ukraine den
zugang zu russischen staatsbürgerschaft
zu erleichtern wie er sagt was eine
zynische umschreibung für die
ratifizierung besetzte gebiete ist die
ukrainische armee führung rechnet
außerdem damit dass sich die russischen
truppen für eine noch stärkere offensive
im osten formieren auch gab es erneut
schwere raketenangriffe auf die
millionenstadt hackl dort ist unser
reporter dara hassanzadeh
wir fahren dorthin wo heute in
die geschosse eingeschlagen sind aus
drei luftangriffe folgte schwerer
artillerie beschuss ein vorgehen mit dem
die russische armee häufig offensiven
militärisch vorbereitet getroffen wurde
dieses auto die insassen vater und sohn
waren nur anhand von dokumenten zu
identifizieren
sie können es selbst sehen da ist nichts
militärischen mitteln
kaum einen kilometer luftlinie entfernt
wurde ein wohnhaus getroffen
jewgeni der nachbar und gegenüber dem
zerstörten haus
es ist ein dauerbeschuss anfangs
schossen sie nachts um 10 dann und 2 uhr
nachts dann um vier uhr in der nacht und
jetzt bombardieren sie auch schon am
formel
gähn ist halb große er gehört zu den
menschen die laut russischer propaganda
befreit werden sollen die ganz racky
dafür nimmt die russische armee die
zerstörung ganzer stadtviertel in kauf
und die verwüstung von jewgeni wohnen
wenn die explosionen passieren ist es zu
spät um noch zu reagieren wenn du sie
hörst dann bedeutet es wenigstens dass
du noch lebst und wenn du sie nicht
gehört hast dann war es das
seine frau war glücklicherweise im
hinterzimmer als die fensterscheiben
barsten
ob diese angriffe teil einer neuen
großoffensive auf rat tief sind werden
die nächsten tage zeigen
mehr informationen und hintergründe zum
kriegsgeschehen und seinen weltweiten
folgen finden sie bei uns wie immer auch
online auf zdf heute ja und eine
pandemie haben wir auch noch damit
beginnen die nachrichten der eu behörden
empfehlen angesichts seiner neuen corona
welle in europa für menschen ab 60 eine
zweite auffrischungsimpfungen betracht
zu ziehen eu kommissar in korea dies
forderte die mitgliedsstaaten auf sofort
eine zweite booster impfung für die
betreffenden gruppen bereitzustellen
laut europäischer gesundheitsbehörde cdc
melden mehrere länder einen zunehmenden
trend bei der aufnahme in krankenhäuser
und intensivstationen
die korona pandemie ist nach angaben der
vereinten nationen auch ein wesentlicher
grund dafür dass die weltweite
lebenserwartung gesunken ist im
vergangenen jahr auf 71 jahre fast zwei
jahre weniger als vor der pandemie laut
dem bericht zum heutigen
weltbevölkerungstag wächst die zahl der
menschen immer langsamer trotzdem wird
erwartet dass die marke von 8 milliarden
im november erreicht wird
im weltsicherheitsrat gibt es nun
möglicherweise doch eine verständigung
auf weitere hilfslieferungen in den
nordwesten syriens wie es am abend hieß
sollen sie zunächst um sechs monate
verlängert werden eine entsprechende
resolution könnte demnach noch heute
abend verabschiedet werden die bisherige
regelung war gestern ausgelaufen und
hilfsorganisationen warnten vor einer
humanitären katastrophe
nach deutschland die ig metall geht mit
einer forderung nach acht prozent mehr
geld in die tarifrunde für die metall
und elektroindustrie
der industriezweig hat rund 3,8
millionen beschäftigte die verhandlungen
wird der arbeitgeberseite sollen mitte
september beginnen und noch die
wetteraussichten morgen gibt es einen
mix aus viel sonne und ein paar wolken
im nordwesten und südosten können die
wollten allerdings auch mal dichter sein
die temperatur steigt auf werte zwischen
22 und 31 grad in den nächsten tagen
steigt die temperatur im süden auf werte
bis 36 grad im norden bleibt es deutlich
kühler hier kann es auch mal einen
schauer geben
das war's auch schon von uns weiter
gehts mit der zweiten halbzeit und ein
ausführliches heute schon ein star
morgen wieder bis dahin wieder sehen
[Musik]